our new gates are open on january 20
2012 police raided a mansion in new
zealand at the request of the fbi
consume located
judging from the military style raid you
think they were after a terrorist or
some other dangerous criminal but the
man renting this mansion north of
auckland was an internet entrepreneur
who ran one of the most popular websites
in the world mega upload was the 13th
most frequently visited site on the
internet at its peak it claimed 50
million daily visits users could view
any files people shared movies music and
tv shows
hello everyone this is kim.com kim.com
also known as kim schmitz or kimball or
kim tim jim vester created mega upload
in 2005. he is larger than life standing
at six foot seven and over 300 pounds as
a successful entrepreneur in his native
germany he had a knack for finding
financial opportunities in technology he
realized back in 2005 that there wasn't
an easy way to send big files to family
and friends so he created mega upload if
a file was too big to share by email you
could upload it to megaupload.com and
then share a unique link so your family
and friends could access the file from
the cloud people did use mega upload for
legitimate purposes however mega upload
made it very easy to share large video
files like movies and tv shows
authorities believe that was the main
money maker sharing pirated content it
wasn't immediately obvious there was
pirated content available as there was
no search feature on the site so you
couldn't specifically look for pirated
movies and shows instead mega upload
relied on third-party sites to publish
urls if you visited alluc.org it would
contain a megaupload.com link or when an
fbi agent investigating the company
visited sidereel.com to search for an
episode of modern family they found 60
urls hosted on mega upload's sister site
megavideo.com which streams video
although copyright holders could submit
a claim to try to get the material taken
down the us government said the takedown
request only removed the url link in
question not the actual copyrighted
content and since multiple urls pointed
to the same file the content would still
be available through other undisclosed
url links
hollywood's major film studios were
livid the fbi accused the mega brand of
costing film studios and record
companies more than 500 million dollars
perhaps in a bid to get some support on
his side kim.com released a bizarre
music video with recording artists and
celebrities praising mega upload when i
gotta send files
[Music]
but apparently that wasn't enough to
appease hollywood
authorities moved in on mega upload
though washington has denied it bowed to
pressure mr.com has been shown the
warrant to change the property they
timed the massive raid to coincide with
dot com's 38th birthday celebration
which they expected would be attended by
other mega executives they also happened
to make the move on the same day u.s
lawmakers axed anti-piracy legislation
after heavy criticism from the public
they found kim.com sheltered in his
panic room inside his mansion with a
shotgun they arrested him as well as
three other executives during the raid
chief marketing officer finn batato lead
programmer braum vanderkulk chief
technical officer matthias ordman they
were charged with racketeering copyright
infringement money laundering and
criminal copyright infringement if the
fbi had their way the men would be
extradited to america each to face up to
55 years in prison mega upload was
officially shut down
usually copyright infringement is a
civil matter and does not constitute a
criminal offence in the u.s dotcom's
lawyers argued that copyright
infringement is not a criminal offence
in new zealand where he was residing at
the time and therefore not an
extraditable offense and besides dotcom
wrote in a blog post how could we be
criminally responsible for the actions
of others as in users who chose to
upload pirated material
apple co-founder steve wozniak made the
same argument pointing out you can't
shut down the post office if someone
sends drugs through the mail and he saw
mega upload as the post office but the
us government saw it differently
washington believed make upload actively
encouraged users to post copyrighted
content and should be held criminally
responsible the department of justice
wrote in this 191-page evidence report
that make a upload's business model
incentivized users to upload popular
pirated content they described how they
had a rewards program that offered to
pay up to ten thousand dollars to users
whose files were downloaded five million
times they say mega upload executives
knew exactly what they were doing citing
a skype conversation in which the chief
programmer said to the chief tech
officer were modern pirates
the mega group apparently raked in a
treasure trove the company is said to
have earned 175 million dollars 25
million from ads and 150 million from
premium memberships which offered faster
unlimited service
dot com wasn't shy about flaunting his
lavish lifestyle in this music video
posted to his youtube channel he showed
off his super yacht luxury cars speed
boats and private jet during the raid
authorities seized millions of dollars
worth of assets including his cars in
artwork dotcom felt the raid was
excessive and blamed it on the quote
subservience of new zealand to the u.s
empire and the corruption at the top of
government turns out new zealand's
intelligence agency illegally spied
on.com leading up to the raid the then
prime minister john key had to publicly
apologize the injustice.com felt he
faced prompted him to set up a new
political organization in new zealand
the internet party however it failed to
win any seats in the new zealand house
of representatives during the 2017
general election and hasn't contested
any elections since
ten years after the raid in june 2022
two executives pleaded guilty to their
involvement in running mega upload as
part of a deal to avoid extradition to
the u.s
if ortman and vanderkult are found
guilty they face a maximum of 10 years
in prison in new zealand which is far
less than what they could have faced in
u.s prison
american prosecutors dropped their bid
to extradite the fourth executive finn
batado after he was diagnosed with
cancer
potato suffered greatly because of the
whole ordeal he had flown in from
germany for dotcom's birthday bash when
he was arrested during the raid and
wasn't allowed to go home he was stuck
in new zealand
dotcom says botado began drinking every
day to drown out his sadness and it made
him sick
during his final years he started a
family in new zealand but wouldn't ever
see his three young children grow up he
passed away in june at the age of 49.
as for his colleagues ortman and
vanderkult say they wanted to put the
decade-long legal saga behind them and
are now contributing to society through
mega a legitimate cloud storage site
they set up after their arrest dot com's
two former colleagues are expected to
testify against him as part of the deal
but he doesn't appear to hold any
grudges tweeting after 10 years of u.s
lawfare i understand why they have given
up i don't blame that and i sincerely
wish them all the best
as for himself dot com is out on bail in
new zealand still fighting extradition
to the us
he frequently posts updates on social
media and life with his children and his
second wife elizabeth donnelly whom he
married on the anniversary of the raid
on january 20 2018. how this saga plays
out could be an important test of just
how far the americans can reach when it
comes to intellectual property rights
kim.com has been cast as a visionary an
online freedom campaigner or if the u.s
government is to be believed a swindler
and a thief which do you think he is
leave me a comment regardless of how you
feel about him he wouldn't be any of
those things without some serious
technology and problem-solving skills if
you'd like to brush up on your stem
skills and build a product that's useful
for people brilliant is the perfect way
to learn interactively you can
strengthen your knowledge of core
computer science concepts through their
computer science fundamentals course you
can solve puzzles with science through
their scientific thinking course or
start your algebra journey with an
introduction to variables and equations
with their pre-algebra course my
personal favorite are the logic courses
that help flex your problem-solving
muscles and build the skills you need to
solve difficult math problems there are
no tests and if you ever get stuck you
can click view explanation for more
there's something for everyone on
brilliant whether you're in school or
already in the workforce brilliant is
free for you to try out if you use the
custom link in my description
brilliant.org
newsthink and the first 200 of you to
click my link will get 20 off their
premium subscription which gives you
unlimited access to all of their
offerings thanks for watching for news
think i'm cindy palm